when Twitter and my Xbox gamer tag is
reckless so it did come from that and
then Tortuga isn't one that I did love
so reckless or two that is Lindsay
Lindsay and I actually went to school
together together yeah and Jason I met
through another friend of ours and then
I kind of like Ben yeah Jason died
together yeah he's levitating we decided
to make sweet movies together another
married never baby and it's all his
fault and the name it Eric it was more
we were trying to find a name for our
company and everything was taken so we
were googling all these different
combinations and this one wasn't taken
and we were kind of like whatever just
take it we didn't know who would become
what it is today and then I start to
channel they're like oh cool they just
placeholder but then you're like
whenever we thought of what to change it
to it was like huh that's very specific
it's good yeah no it was better than
anything else we could think of we tried
to think of other things about for its
and stuff no not at all when I came from
was for some random reason II how to say
seeing Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles in
Spain
it's funny I know this on tiny Italians
are tortured go that way I think are all
kind of Moody yeah I always have pretty
funny mood swings
yeah and we never know who's gonna show
up to a meeting if they're gonna be
don't be jason happy Jason you know it's
funny we've been doing this for five
years so when we first started we
literally probably spent anywhere from
60 to 70 hours a week together when you
spend that much time with somebody
you're bound to see them pissed off
you're bound to see them exhausted
you're bound to see them going through
whatever life problem what they're gonna
go through and I think it is kind of a
testament that we've been able to stay
together through all of that because
there's no there's no other two other
people that I don't know but I spend
more time with them
oh so it's like it is what it is we are
just around each other it's like yeah
yeah I mean usually at their house
stroll in and it's like what what are we
doing cool so we don't actually fight as
much as you think we don't really have
to make this again we just talk it out
ya know we're not like very contentious
for each other at all yeah I think we're
all very passionate about what we
believe and we're all three completely
different people and have three
different approaches and I think that
that kind of lends itself to the content
on our channel because it's not just all
one person it's it's been banged around
and pinballed back and forth to finally
arrive at where it is and we try
bringing other people into into the
group for some reason what we have works
but we have been able to expand on that
with like that's how we have a writers
room now with more writers and but
bringing in other people unlike the
business end
lately reckless search you're gonna like
that work it doesn't work it doesn't
work because also people don't realize
how much time you spend together they
don't realize the time enough I think I
could do that you're like we meet every
day
deal with it whether it's on the phone
whether it's you know in person yeah
the plan basically is a spin-off show of
online gamer we we love making online
gamer but it is a bit difficult to come
up with scenarios for just like one
person and after 63 episodes of that
show we really kind of wanted to bring
like um breathe new life into it yeah
and there's a good environment for Erin
because no one really likes it it's hard
to keep him like I guess it's somewhat
believable that he's in this
relationship with this insane gamer girl
but besides her we are I don't have any
other characters who can say what this
guy so pregnant clan was a great way for
him to be with other people around and
they're not like they don't get along
all the time that they they're together
yeah or together and join together by
the common goal of trying to be the best
I was getting this location and this
girl we're going to use our house and I
was like cool so it's great it's for the
series called the clan and she was like
yeah totally all right I'm totally fine
with that and then she freaked out the
night before and was like I was just
talking to my husband is this about the
cool my lawn I was like no I was like no
it's about this and she was like oh okay
I just I just was freaking out for a
second so that could be something that
people actually think I never thought of
that until she brought it up that what
it is that's what it is in gaming and
authenticity is kind of important to us
so it wasn't just the clan we've had a
great experience with them we've been
we've been with them for three years now
and time and they're good to us I mean
whatever we call them on the phone they
pick up the answer they handle all of
our problems
yeah I mean it's been a it's been a
great relationship they've been able to
do a lot of things that I don't think we
would have had that opportunity happy
now yeah the clan I mean is entirely
from Michonne enough like we weren't
signed with anyone or even looking for
it and when mission that came along we
were pretty particular on what we wanted
and they facilitated that and maintain
Lissa's support because we really we
want this kind of sport in this kind of
sport we don't need that we don't need
that because we're different than other
youtubers or production companies online
like we have very specific needs innate
they fulfilled it and they continue
helping us which is great I think these
two do I sit behind amber
I don't really get it as much but Eric
like will be shooting out on the street
and people who like literally honk their
horn in scream the Southland story is my
favorite story though yeah but that was
the first time ever that I got
recompenses and that was awesome
cuz I was on set of style and I was like
the second episode I was just like a bit
roll and I was on the ground and they
were in between takes and everyone left
the set so is empty and we were on a
we're in a convenience store this kid
comes in holy [ __ ] are you from reckless
searching good then I was like yeah I am
from reckless or two yet means that no
go ahead any reason this guy seems that
sound like my story eighty million times
like so mom guess what
yeah it's awesome I love it I love it
when when people come up in our I our
fans it's good cuz sometimes we get
detached from it just becomes numbers
you know like just numbers of people
watching our stuff and when people come
pants and tell you that you're like okay
these are actually people you are just
numbers you're right I think YouTube is
the only medium in which people in their
basement are making stuff something that
is being viewed by the entire world you
know like I think when you do a
television show and there's Bill
- TV commercials and interviews and this
that the other ads you kind of inundated
with the promotion of a television show
you understand when people come up to
those people and they're like oh my god
you're on a TV show but for us do this
in my garage so it's odd when people
come up and they're like oh my god
reckless or to get like it almost is
surreal because you you do kind of don't
think about it in that sense you don't
always think about it from the viewers
perspective if when we first got on
YouTube there was really not that many
people doing narrative on YouTube it was
it was a lot of video bloggers it was a
lot of cat videos it was a lot of like
like look what I shot an epic cannon and
we kind of had this approach to scripted
content and like trying to do scripted
content from the beginning in to make it
look on YouTube and now it feels like
everybody's doing that you know I mean
it feels like that's the the new thing
is like just everybody has a web series
there's others you know hoanib scripted
content out there which is really cool
for us but everything can change you
know I don't this space changes on like
a three month cycle it seems like every
three months there's always something
kind of new and different and yeah you
know so I I actually don't know where
the webseries world goes I mean I feels
like more and more things are going to
the web and then eventually they're
gonna merge in some way but I don't know
it's hard to say what I hope is that
they're actually starts to become some
sort of focus on quality because you
watch these ten minute episodes from
some of these web series in your like
Jesus
this is so long for a mediocre
storytelling you know because when
you're watching if I'm gonna invest over
three minutes into something I want it
to be good like I give you three minutes
bagging a few minutes almost any
of watching cat sleep you know it's
doing whatever but if it's more than
that that's why I hope is I hope and
that's what's great about money and
funded content and one of the exciting
things about the Klan you know is
getting opportunities to create a higher
quality content you know to bring the
quality of the space up I think that's
what the future is
yeah but at the same time I see like
certain changes in like the YouTube
space and and how that shifts and
becomes harder and harder to launch a
narrative yeah you know like you do have
a lot of investment coming into web
series and that's great but when we
first started our videos would have
almost a five to seven day life span in
this subscriber box two years later
maybe a three day window as of today I
would say we have 12 hours each you know
and I mean in in someone speed which for
a narrative show which has a lot of
investment in time and resources and so
on and so forth it's hard to compete
with someone who can pump out two videos
a day or even gameplay like if you look
at the explosion of gamers online right
now it's it's it's content that I that
they can just pump out they can pump
that content out and I can't compete as
a scripted channel I can't compete with
a gaming channel and just so you look at
the rise of those those gamers and you
go yeah that this system is kind of set
up for them and and it's in their favor
to some extent especially on YouTube
it's also a new form of entertainment
and it's also a new home of
entertainment and it's great you know I
I don't I'm not hating on the gamers at
all I love I love their stuff and we
have a gaming channel as well but I
would say like where there's money
coming in to webseries there's also
platform changes that are working
against
you know and so that's why I mean I
don't I don't know what's gonna happen I
would hope that like Eric was saying
quality raises with investment and they
figure out a way to kind of surface this
this kind of great content a tennis this
kind of independent don't make a
revolution that's happening online yes
but you kind of feel like people people
like to that rises to the top you want
to like patrol the streets yes yeah no
that's like yes I would be I think about
the police officer a teacher for sure
that's that's amazing I mean if I wasn't
able to do anything like this I was able
do any sort of filmmaking I don't think
I I wouldn't be a painter or anything
yeah that'd be police I was very
dangerous
I had the worst boiling most boring
answer I probably work computers because
that's what I did it's not fair like
make money while I was trying to support
my filmmaking career graphic designers
no no like literally a probably like
builder I can hurt you use your [ __ ]
computer that means with a blue shirt on
you love that [ __ ] yeah yeah I'd be like
a [ __ ] these two didn't have the
store
so thanks guys so much for watching our
interview okay or do we like to order
now we don't need so you can read the
written version on the website when
they're rock stars calm with our share
photo shoot - yeah good stuff but also
like favorite comment and subscribe the
holy you know in a Jew you're on YouTube
that's enough the quadrant IV quadrant
development in what is it no we're not
what driller cheap copy righted
trademarked yeah